alors maintenant je les rejoigne
quelqu'un qui refusent pour des raisons
de sécurité un peu comme vous l'a la
semaine dernière patrick bd et
d'apparaître sur un plateau de
télévision avec du avec du public
elle s'appelle ni maza mars et une ex
espionne israélienne et vous allez voir
elle balance tout
[Musique]
il
m
soit entière du sort des masses marc
alors j'ai voulu qu'on se retrouve ici
c'est pour des raisons de sécurité je
préfère effectivement kippot public
autour
quand je fais une télévision - vous avez
peur d'être reconnue oui ni maze a marre
c'est pas votre vrai nom c'est mon nom
c'est mon identité réelle sur le terrain
alors vous êtes juive française famille
d'origine roumaine sa exterminés dans
l'est dans les camps nazis est à 22 ans
vous décidez de faire votre alias c'est
à dire votre retour en israël
absolument oui pourquoi c'était pour moi
une évidence
en tant que juive et puis parce qu'il me
retenait plus rien en france je pensais
que c'était bien de refaire ma vie
entièrement de cet indiscret vous ai
vécu jusqu'à 22 en france vous avez un
accent quand même c'est cressier j'ai
tellement d'accent si vous saviez alors
comme en israël tant qu'on n'a pas fait
son service militaire on n'est pas
vraiment intéressant
voilà vous faites votre service et puis
pour vous c'est aussi une façon de
prendre votre revanche sur votre mère
qui avait été tellement traumatisée par
parler quand oui que chaque fois qu'elle
voyait un uniforme elle elle était
complètement paniquée oui c'est vrai
c'est une façon de nettoyer un passé
douloureux
j'ai pensé faire un service simple pas
du tout un risque de combat ou de
service contre soit toujours en service
où on donne des cours aux civils ou des
choses qu'on tient service tranquille
alors comme vous êtes ingénieur en
informatique dans l'armée israélienne
vous vous avez travaillé sur
l'informatique et vous trouver la faille
du système informatique
ouais c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
l'office y arrive un soir et me dit
qu'il a perdu un fichier machine sur un
réseau me demande comme un service si je
peux pas le dépanner j'avais
l'impression que ça risque d'être un
piège bien sûr c'est un peu gros mais
d'un autre côté je pouvais pas refuser
et puis je me suis pris au jeu en même
temps et effectivement j'ai réussi à
casser la fac du service enfin la
sécurité du réseau
c'est pas difficile à casser et alors là
vos supérieurs vous leurs proches après
c'est là qu'après quand vous les
demandes et on vous le reproche et on
exerce sur vous une forme de chantage en
vous disant maintenant si tu veux pas
être poursuivi batta qu'une chose à
faire finalement c'est travail voilà
absolument pas été piégé
oui je ne se fait piéger mais le premier
pas et forcés dans souvent je n'étais
pas la seule à qui ça mais ensuite le
dès le lendemain on est complètement
pris en charge par toute une équipe qui
vous soutient psychologiquement qui
s'entraîne physiquement qui vous parle
de votre action du sens qu'elle peut
avoir du service que vous allez rendre
au [ __ ] dit que vous avez sauvé et c'est
fini je veux dire le chantage ça dure
quoi séduire une journée ouais c'est
juste un pas à franchir que je n'aurais
jamais franchi moi même je ne serais pas
engagé je ne va pas postuler pour une
place dans ce genre de cyence et ensuite
j'ai continué par par patriotisme ma
propre
alors là vous subissez une formation
dans le but d'infiltrer le hesbollah le
hesbollah tu sais les milice chiite
libanaise alors vous apprenez enduré des
passages à tabac par exemple comment ça
se passe graduellement et ça prend
beaucoup de temps c'est un entraînement
qui se fait pour pas braquer les gens
pour pas qu'il y ait de révolte non plus
franches on s'habitue graduellement à
des coûts bien dire comme c'est des cons
coup je pas non plus rentrer dans le
détail parce que bon c'est c'est
particulièrement pénible et puisse
rentrer dans ce genre de service
c'est un passage obligé de 10 en gros de
subir une torture ouais jusqu'au là
jusqu'à la torture et le lavage de
cerveau c'est pourquoi j'ai parlé de
lavage de cerveau tu pas varié la magie
c'est anti tu parlais de
d'endoctrinement différent quand même
pas tellement non c'est vrai que c'est
tellement difficile psychologiquement de
tenir le coup d'abord parmi des gens
qu'on ne respecte pas qu'on estime pas
j'ai par des terroristes pas des
palestiniens ne me fait pas un faux
procès je n'accuse pas les palestiniens
jeunes et pas les palestiniens mais
c'est sûr quand on est dans les groupes
terroristes qui sont violents ivres de
haine
un monde un milieu socialement
donc je n'avais pas l'habitude quand
même moi j'ai vécu en france au départ
certain confort jeu il faut ne pas
oublier pourquoi on travaille donc c'est
vrai que ce que vous appelez donc lavage
de cerveau ce que j'appelle un autre
immense que jérôme soutien psychologique
c'est c'est ce que j'ai mis en fait d'un
tout au long du livre ces caractères
graal et les récits des attentats qui
sont produits pendant ces dix ans on
vous demande des fautes il vous montre
des films on est en éveil votre haine
contre ces terroristes non c'est pas de
la haine c'est vraiment pas de la haine
c'est la conscience de ce qu'on peut
apporter pour sauver des vies voyez ça
j'y tiens absolument à marquer ça il ya
une différence
je ne suis pas ce métier pour détruire
des palestiniens ou des terroristes on
fait ce métier pour construire l'état
d'israël et sauver des vies et c'est
cette écologie leur que nous avons là
ensuite une fois que la formation est
terminée on vous introduit donc au
hezbollah ou fait passer pour pour une
fille assez riche en héritière de
palestiniens émigrés ans en suisse et
qui a envie de consacrer sa fortune a
été estimée à soutenir la cause mais ils
en crue oui oui pensez que son anniv non
je pensais qu'une pense se gérer la
situation de façon et puis ça les
intéresse
lorsque vous dit qui est assez critique
pour la pour la france où vite ayant été
élevé avec les idées de la gauche
française
finalement j'ai pas eu de mal
ah d'accord avec enfants tous les cas
leur faire croire que j'étais d'accord
avec eux oui c'est ça je connaissais le
discours je connais certains discours
programme pro palestiniens donc j'ai pas
eu de mal à répéter ce discours page
était paru c'est vrai alors après six
mois avec ces palestiniens vous partez
dans un camp d'entraînement du hezbollah
en libye et la vo chef vous ordonne et
c'est un des moments les plus brefs
délais j'avais mon les plus forts du
bouquin et leur donne de d'assassiner
une combattante de votre âge qui
s'appelle yasmina et sans sourciller
vous voulez tremblay pour moi mon métier
au départ c'est l'informatique intégrée
c'est arrivé à pirater ses ordinateurs
il fallait que je m'intègre dans un
groupe de terrorisme faut les rejoindre
effectivement le passage obligé c'était
ce camp d'entraînement ça voulu dire
obéir à leurs codes obéir à leurs règles
et jouer le jeu comme un combattant il
ya dans ces camps d'entraînement un
processus de déshumanisation qui est
très important qui est même le plus
important c'est pas demander des corps
paramilitaires ou technologies avancées
pas du tout c'est
dès qu'une amitié détecter donné l'ordre
à chacun des deux amis de tuer l'autre
et puis voir celui qui aura le courage
c'est particulièrement cruel ça a été
décrit par d'autres que par mois mais
bon les gens formés vous au moment où
vous l'étrangler vous pensez quoi
moi j'étais justement comme je savais
que ça avait déjà été décrit je savais
que ça risque de produire j'avais été
préparé à ça mais pour moi la rigueur
c'était moins difficile que pour eux
parce que ils ont enfin je veux dire que
ça arrive à des palestiniens et des
libanais vivant dans ces cas là c'est
entre je dirais même partisan du mêmes
causes qui sont avec moi je suis un
ennemi quelqu'un qui allait
éventuellement mettre des bombes contre
des israéliens
c'est un être humain yasmina quand même
vous êtes c'est une guerre et pour
rentrer pour faire ce que j'avais à
faire après il fallait infiltrer ce
groupe il fallait faire ce qu il fallait
le faire donc je les fais oui mais je
les fais comme un soldat fait une
mission je veux dire j'ai pas fait ni
par plaisir ni par indifférence ni par
quoi que ce soit elle vous a dit quelque
chose avant de mourir non j'ai pas
souvenir qu'elle dit je vous ai
regardées je les fais dodo un fer de
face c'est quand même plus difficile et
le lendemain on attend vos réveillons
dès le soir même je t'ai pris un projet
violent évidemment si on fait pas
en plus c'est la première fois que j'ai
tué quelqu'un et de près je veux dire
c'est pas comme vous quand vous tirer
sur quelqu'un qui a à 200 m mais surpris
en rouge et blanc mais comme encore une
fois excusez de psychologiquement sauver
d'éviter plus important que dans ces
moments là vous continuer à vivre comme
une femme c'est à dire à vous maquiller
à vous occuper de vous oui oui tous les
jours oui c'est important c'est aussi le
vendre à un des jours vous avez tué dix
mines à vous maquiller comme
normalement non pas d'un camp
d'entraînement à la non mais après dans
le reste ma vie oui vous avez tués
combien de gens dans votre vie j'ai pas
compté combien de gens de j'ai tué on
doit bien décompté quand même quand on
tue des gens c'est pas un nom parce que
quand vous voulez occulter vous comptez
pas juste alors là où c'est encore plus
difficile c'est qu'à un moment vous
recevez une mission qui est de vous
faire arrêter pour implanter des
mouchards dans les ordinateurs des
services de sécurité syriens est alors
dans ce cas là c'est encore pire parce
que vous êtes obligé de faire attention
à ce que votre victime ne meurt pas trop
vite pour qu'elle ait le temps de
prévenir ses amis et que vous soyez
arrêté ouais mais c'est arrivé une fois
attention c'était quelqu'un qui m'avait
avant d'énoncer aux syriens comme ayant
des activités anti syrienne je me suis
fait arrêter et torturer interrogés et
c'est cette même personne effectivement
je les tue et un peu plus tard dans des
conditions un peu pénible c'est vrai
mais bon c'est un cas un peu unique
exceptionnel vous a été torturé on vous
apprend à supporter la la torture
pendant votre formation vous amène dans
les hôpitaux on vous demande des gens
qui ont des cancers avancés on vous
montre des gens qui sont amputés de
façon à vous habituer et finalement à la
jeune plaignent pas trop
oui j'ai été victime de torture
chimiques c'est par injection ça fait
quel effet une douleur atroce celle que
j'avais ressenti une douleur qui comme
comment dire aiguë qui remontaient qui
ont remonté le corps jusqu'au cerveau
jusqu'à voir l'impression que le coeur
ou du cerveau va exploser on sait pas
lequel le veut le faire le premier c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable parce
que c'est en nous quand vous prenez un
coup c'est plus supportable parce que ça
vienne extérieur est bon ça les
tortionnaires le savent très bien
c'est un monde vous avez été violée non
j'ai fait près les intéressés non c'est
bizarre quand même
bussières bah oui parce qu'on peut
penser qu'à partir de mots et vous
torture nous pouvons profiter enfin je
viens c'est mais c'était pas le cas vous
savez il ya un tel mépris même façon que
je sais pas en fait jugé une sur une
expliqué tout décorative ou torturé il
s'occupait de votre sexe oui il ya des
tortures par des matraques électriques
la torture est effectivement bien
esquinté d'ailleurs quand après j'ai eu
ma petite fille c'était difficile oui
alors après ça quand vous avez quitté le
service donc que vous nommez pas mais
dont on a bien compris que c'était le
mossad convient comment dans un système
vous comprenez on n'est pas l'horizon
ouais on a une action qui en est un
héros ou l'héroïne en tout cas elle peut
pas bien sûr les puis on a des
compétences on passe dans un autre
système
ce qu'on sait faire ne sert à rien en
fait on ne sait rien faire et en plus on
n'est pas valorisé du tout et
c'est difficile à vivre forcément oui
oui j'ai une dépression à ce moment là
une petite dépression mais surtout on
peut la sortie avait été difficile et
puis et puis j'avais eue
j'en avais assez de ces destructions de
ces violences et c'est là que j'avais
commencé justement suivre des cours de
krav maga ont permis de me reconstruire
physiquement tu ne cesses défense en
fait oui oui mais surtout ça donne à
l'individu par le le fait qu'ils
s'autorisent à se défendre
pour ma part c'était défendu c'est et
politiquement incorrect m'a fallu
encaisser et pas faire de vagues
donc quand j'ai basculé dans ce
processus
d'avoir le droit d'exister d'avoir le
droit de me défendre d'avoir le droit de
vivre etc
c'était énorme pour moi et ça a été une
reconstruction psychologique
fondamentale psychothérapie aussi
j'imagine fait des cauchemars encore oui
ça c'est inévitable faut que vous voyez
quoi dans ses cauchemars
des cris des des sentiments de peur ou
hausse et surtout les tortures qu'ils en
escrime plus de souffrance vous voyez
des gens que vous avez tué non sauf un
qui était un tortionnaire
mais tu après alors ensuite vous avez
fait un enfant
malheureusement son père a été tué
quelques quelques mois plus tard c'est
dans ce même service que vous gide
inquiète parce que quand vous avez subi
ces tortures chimiques peut-être ya des
choses qui restaient dans votre corps
j'avais encore des crises régulières
main juste pas quelle était la part des
chemins et les médecins non plus avait
pas très moyen parce que j'ai des
produits assez inconnu en même temps oui
et puis malheureusement ça évolue mais
l'enfant est bien avec les hommes
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui alors
c'est d'être formidable pour de draguer
matin ils ont tagué mathari oui de vivre
avec elles n'ont pas dit non parce que
il ya une telle incompréhension des deux
mondes
et puis moi même chez des moments de je
me replie sur moi même je pense à autre
chose et tu vois ce monde qui ne
connaissent pas et qui nous qu'elles
n'auront pas accès c'est pas possible
donc pour l'instant je vais pas trop le
truc chiant vous êtes seul oui
la solitude convient à deux avec une
incompréhension totale de l'autre c'est
encore pire donc c'est vrai vous effet
le livre pourquoi j'ai fait livres pour
sortir de ce milieu et j'ai fait le
livre pour passer un message aux gens
qui font le même métier que ces
processus de reconstruction que j'ai
entrepris moi même s'ils veulent
entreprendre c'est pas une mauvaise
chose le père de ma fille comme vous
l'avez dit a été tué parce que justement
il suivait la politique officielle de
rester passif d'encaisser les coups etc
il a pris mauvais cours on avait eu
avant une discussion ensemble assez fou
soutenu pour essayer de le convaincre de
faire du krav maga technique défense qui
sont plus discrètes je veux dire c'est
basé sur des réflexes et pas les
techniques de karaté ou pousser un cri
vous avez des gestes scientifique mais
il n'avait pas voulu faire parce qu'il
tenait son avancement à être bientôt
faire une carrière et c'est donc ce que
je voudrais passer comme message au
milieu peut-être je sais que en israël
l'intérêt de l'individu de passe
derrière l'intérêt général ouais
beaucoup lager oui mais un peu trop
peut-être remonter un tout petit peu
l'intérêt de l'individu ne nuirait pas
du tout à son efficacité c'est le
message que je passe ça vous protège
d'avoir fait ce livre
oui parce que les ce livre je montre
quand même la moitié mon visage à
découvert et les gens qui me connaissent
me reconnaissent et mon nom et mon
opérationnelle sur le terrain je veux
dire à ceux du métier d'un bord comme de
l'autre
le troisième mort que j'arrête ce genre
de métier maintenant je veux qu'on me
foute la paix alors vous avez pas peur
du hezbollah parce que quand même
vous avez trahi vous avez tué des leur
faisait pas peur c'est à dire aller
promener là où ils ont leurs
implantations c'est sûr maintenant ici
je vous vois non en quoi il viendrait me
chercher que non plus le fait de
reconnaître qu'ils ont été roulés par
une femme c'est l'horreur absolue et le
menaça le mossad vous pourriez en avoir
peur parce que vous avez été victime
quand vous êtes parti à l'aéroport par
une micro seringue comme ça d'une
tentative d'assassinât
oui mais en même temps il m'avait
prévenu donc c'est toujours c'est cette
duplicité qui a de ce genre de milieu
manipulation des gens qui est assez
forte donc c'est si on voulait me tuer
ou à mourir depuis longtemps voilà ce
que je pense
alors comme vous le savez certains
mettent en doute la crédibilité de votre
votre récit d'abord le recrutement par
chantage
on dit que c'est pas vrai avec les repas
les gens comme ça oui non recrutés gens
et puis on dit aussi qu'il ya pas de
camp hezbollah en syrie sont plutôt au
sud liban le camp du hezbollah
c'est bien ce que j'ai dit c'est un
tribun j'ai un journaliste fait un
amalgame et ils sont aussi liban j'ai
fait des incursions syrie du camp
sentimentaux
on dit aussi qu'à l'époque manipulés par
les syriens comme on dit aussi qu'à
l'époque dont vous parlez mais pas
suffisamment d'ordinateurs en syrie pour
que quelqu'un soit envoyé pour coller
des mouchards dans ses ordinateurs non
mais c'est vrai il n'est pas
d'ordinateur un syrie d'ailleurs on n'a
jamais été un syrie et d'ailleurs je
sais même pas si ça existe là c'est non
non il faut être raisonnable
non c'est tout à fait vrai nom le ce
livre pour l'écrire j'aurais dû attendre
30 ans à ce moment là j'aurais pu donner
des noms des lieux des dates des
précisions et puis ne pas mettre en
danger les choses qui peuvent
éventuellement tourner encore dans des
ordinateurs qui n'existe pas mais j'ai
essayé de faire quand même un livre
parce que pour ma survie c'était
important
je remercie au passage l'éditeur
festayres d'alain michel absolument quel
courage de le publier de risquer sa
réputation
mon témoignage c'est courageux mais j'ai
essayé de ne pas mettre quoi que ce soit
qui puisse faire courir des risques aux
gens sur eux même si après ça m'est
reproché comme un manque de preuves
pensez pas que c'est le mossad qui fait
courir des bruits sur la véracité de
votre aventure service secret israélien
alors il ya un truc aussi qui arrange
pas la crédibilité de votre affaire mais
c'est peut-être vrai ça fait un petit
rimer sens c'est que l'attentât du world
trade center ont été commis par les
russes en fait parce que vous expliquez
que d'abord vous dites les arabes sont
incapables sur le plan technique de
faire quelque chose d'aussi difficile et
vous dites qu à part le gps finalement
le seul guidage pour tomber juste dans
les tours c'est le glonass et le guidage
russie rapporte une conversation que
j'avais eue avec des camarades à ce
sujet après le 11 septembre parce qu'on
était tous très étonné de cette histoire
d'al qaïda je vous explique pourquoi
d'abord la façon de procéder et parable
je veux dire ce doublé précis sur des
tours c'est pas leurs enfants détourner
un avion et le jeter au pif sur la ville
oui mais bon pour ce que non nous savons
connaissons des arabes des connaissances
des russes oui on avait l'impression que
c'était plutôt parce que on peut pas
échapper à des services secrets de la
planète entière pendant des années
c'était un plan qui a été monté sur des
années et c'est pas non plus dans la
mentalité arabe de prévoir des plans sur
une longue durée et le garçon dénommé ac
qui vous avait parlé de ça
spécialiste du lucre m oui et morts dans
cet avion qui a été descendu par un
missile quelques semaines plus tard
évidemment accidentellement un missile
absolument accidentel tiré par les
ukrainiens donc vous n'êtes pas
mythomane vous n'êtes pas la nouvelle
nikita
non non non vraiment pas lui qui tannait
non s'il vous plaît j'ai une super
espionne alors pas super je suis
quelqu'un d'ordinaire quelqu'un
d'ordinaire qui s'est retrouvé embringué
dans un processus c'est ça que je veux
et écrit aussi dans ce livre sachez
aussi faire attention dans quoi vous
mettez les pieds parce que on pense
toujours à moi ça n'arrivera pas et moi
je n'en veux pas moi je ne fais rien de
tout ça et puis en fait pas après pas on
se retrouve impliqué dans des histoires
il faut bien qu'on avoir conscience que
ça prend des années c'est pas du jour si
c'était à refaire
j'espère que ce sera parfait
je sais pas vous échapper rien le
lendemain du jour où ils vous ont mis
sur le dos le l'histoire l'ordinateur
probablement vous allez faire quoi là ce
soir c'est soir je vais retrouver ma
petits cubes et puis je vais bientôt
partir ailleurs loin au soleil je sais
pas on va arriver dans l'hiver de façon
non mais je sais je sais j'essaye de
refaire ma vie non plus trouvé un métier
trouvez vous normal
merci
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
alors je n'ai pas eu brûlées vives
maintenant il ya mata hari ça fait 1
mais c'est toi qui avais dit ça il
fallait faire des émissions masquer leur
estime et ouais ouais mais non je n'en
sais rien c'est vrai que moi au moins
j'ai l'honnêteté d'écrire un roman sur
la couverture de mon livre - on sait que
c'est inventé
je sais pas non j'en sais rien je
marquais le voir je me sens plus proche
d'elle que de n'importe quel écrivain
français vivant skis et ski très
intéressant de voir c'est un peu ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure c'est que c'est une
combattante 1 et ça n'empêche pas d'être
légère d'être avoir du charme de de rire
et tout en étant extrêmement profonde
elle a dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
elle a dit c'est la guerre et la raison
c'est la guerre alors vous auriez
interrogé un kamikaze palestinien
il vous aurait certainement raconté à
peu près la même chose dans l'autre camp
il ya aussi des gens qui sont des jeunes
gens qui croient encore à quelque chose
et préférait pas que ces gens-là et
envie de faire la paix plutôt que la
guerre c'est pas l'heure de la paix et
c'est l'heure de la guerre et il faut
qu'il y ait des gens qui ce qui con
comme elle même si je suis absolument
pas d'accord
et depuis c'est compliqué alors non
moins je sais pas si c'est vrai aussi
c'est faux ça va un peu fait froid dans
le dos quand on racontait ces exécutions
et puis je comprends pas qu'on puisse
épouser des idées jusqu'au point de tuer
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi traversé
la vie sans tuer personne enfin moi
c'est un minimum garanti quoi dans sur
cette terre sain et ça m'a rappelé une
scène de 2
deux films l'armée des ombres qu'en
abandonnant il faut tuer un collabo et
qui sait de dire ça au sort et ça c'est
très très stressant et prenant est-ce
que c'est son histoire vraie qui sont
vraiment passé mais qui pose des cas de
conscience à tout le monde quoi bien
merci à tous et puis j'espère qu'elle
s'en sortira pas ce qu'elle est très
très inquiète quand il pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux